on this channel we quite like Stargate
we talk about it quite a lot it might be
our favorite show so imagine how excited
we got when we found out we might have
the
opportunity to talk to that
guy welcome to sidre your SciFi TV and
Movie
[Music]
Channel on Saturday the 14th the
companion is hosting a celebration of
Stargate it is going to be epic they're
bringing together citrek that's us gate
World dial the gate and three5 short I
really that's a great name for podcast
three5 short I really wish I'd thought
of
it they're bringing us together
with that
guy to celebrate Stargate we genuinely
believe just around the the corner we
might be getting a new Stargate
franchise movie series whatever so why
not celebrate this possibly momentous
time for Stargate fans by talking to
Brad Wright of course that that guy
we're going to be able to get to ask him
some really cool questions some fans
have really already put in some
brilliant ones but I'd love you to add
some more here in the comments we'll see
if any of them make the cut dial the
gate gate world and three fry short are
also going to be asking him questions
we're going to have a nice round table
about what we think about the MGM
acquisition and what we think about the
possible reboot or reimagining or
whatever the hell they decide to do of
the Stargate franchise we're going to
actually get an opportunity to get an
insight into Stargate that we rarely get
to have by asking the questions to Brad
you want answered so on Saturday the
14th at 700 p.m. here in the UK come and
join us now you don't have to join us on
Sidetrack if you don't want to oh no
because this is going to be
simultaneously cast between the
companion gate World dial the gate and
three fry short good name for podcast
and obviously us on Sidra now I would
love you to join us of course I would
but really go to whichever of the
channels you like the most hit a like
regardless flip between all four or five
if you want to and hit likes on all of
them because we want to make ourselves
heard we want to make some noise that
the heavens well Amazon will hear and we
want
Stargate we want it
badly so let's celebrate and let's talk
to that guy not not not not not not that
guy even though it would be cool or that
guy that would be
cool so comeing join us hopefully some
of your favorite YouTubers while we're
talking to Brad Wright and we're talking
everan Stargate we cannot wait to
[Music]
see